i wrote the dune series because i had
this idea
that charismatic leaders ought to come
with a warning label on the forehead may
be dangerous to your health
one of the most dangerous presidents
that we've had in this century
was jack kennedy because people said yes
sir mr charismatic leader what do we do
next
and we wound up in vietnam and i think
probably the most
valuable president of this century
was richard nixon because he taught us
to distrust government and he did it by
example
well anyway i wanted to do this thing
about messiahs and charismatic leaders
i mean why do 900 people go to guyana
and drink poison kool-aid
why do the citizens of an entire nation
most of the citizens anyway say sieg
heil and
murder some three million jews
and gypsies why do they not question
their leaders
[Music]
[Applause]
so
do
[Music]
such a rich store of myths enfold paul
muadeeb
the mintat emperor and his sister
aaliyah it is difficult to see the real
persons behind these veils
but there were after all a man born
paul atreides and a woman born aaliyah
their flesh was subject to space and
time
and even though their oracular powers
placed them beyond the usual limits of
time and space
they came from humans stuck they
experienced real events which left real
traces upon a real universe
to understand them it must be seen that
their catastrophe
was the catastrophe of all mankind
this work is dedicated then not to
muadim
or his sister but to their heirs
all of us
each novel in the doom saga preceding
dune
deals with the effects of paul's legacy
on the known universe
dune messiah and children of doom most
of all
at the start of messiah we are
immediately faced with the problems
surrounding paul's rule of the imperium
dune messiah opens with a recorded
interrogation
between a friman priest and a historian
named bronzo
who has been labeled a heretic and
sentenced to death
for his accurate writings on emperor
paul muaddim
twelve years have passed since the
events of dune
at this point paul atreides rules from
arrakis
as emperor of the imperium though paul
is the most powerful
emperor ever he is still incapable of
stopping the lethal religious
excesses of the juggernaut that he has
created
the jihad has been unleashed and it has
conquered most of the known universe
61 billion people have died so far due
to paul's decision to become the messiah
of the fremen people
but according to paul's vision this is
nowhere close to the worst possible
outcome for humanity
it is in dune messiah that paul begins
the golden path
a complex and perilous plan to set
humanity
on a course that will not lead to its
eventual stagnation
and extinction at the same time
paul must balance this with his duties
as ruler of the galactic empire
and as the center of the freman religion
simultaneously the outlying powers in
the universe are growing restless with
the new status quo
several forces are at work and conspire
together to undo
paul atreides and reverse the events
that led to his ascension to the throne
these forces include the bini jesuit
sisterhood
who are vexed that they have lost
control of their quizatz haderac
the remnants of the displaced house
clarino the former occupants of the
throne
the spacing guild who are now under
paul's control due to his control over
the spice
and the many tyleks who have their own
agenda
the tlalac zoo have sent the face dancer
sky tale as their representative
despite the murderous nature of the plot
he hoped to devise
the thoughts of sky tale that slay lack
su face dancer
returned again and again to ruthful
compassion
i shall regret causing death and misery
to mua deem
he told himself he kept this benignity
carefully hidden from his fellow
conspirators
such feelings told him though that he
found it easier to identify with the
victim
than with the attackers a thing
characteristic of talalaksu
skytal stood in bemused silence somewhat
apart from the others
the argument about psychic poison had
been going on for some time now
it was energetic and vehement but polite
that blindly compulsive way that adepts
have the great schools always adopted
for matters close to their dogma when
you think you have him skewered right
then you find him unwounded
that was the old reverend mother of the
bini jesuit
gaius helen mohammed their host is here
on wallet nine
she was a black robe stick figure a
witch crone
seated in a floater chair at skytale's
left her abba hood
had been thrown back to expose a
leathery face
beneath silver hair deeply pocketed eyes
stared out of skull mask
features they were using a mirabasta
language
hone philange consonants and joined
vowels
it was an instrument for conveying fine
emotional subtleties
edric the guild steersman replied to the
reverend mother now with a vocal curtsy
contained in a sneer a lovely touch of
disdainful politeness
skytel looked at the guild envoy edric
swam
in a container of orange gas only a few
paces away
his container sat in the center of the
transparent dome
which the bennie jesuit had built for
this meeting
the guildsman was an elongated figure
vaguely humanoid with thin
feet and hugely fanned membranous hands
a fish
in a strange sea his tank's vents
emitted a pale orange cloud
rich with the smell of the geriatric
spice melange
if we go on this way we'll die of
stupidity
that was the fourth person present a
potential member of the conspiracy
princess ireland wife but not maped
skytale reminded himself of their mutual
foe
she stood at a corner of edric's tank a
tall blonde beauty
splendid in a robe of blue whale fur and
matching hat
gold buttons glittered at her ears she
carried herself with an aristocrat's
auteur
but something in the absorbed smoothness
of her features betrayed the controls of
her benny jesuit background
the atreides dynasty has become less
secure
due to paul not producing an heir at
first it is unclear why
but it is later revealed that the
princess ireland has been secretly
administering contraceptives to paul's
lover and concubine chani
when ireland arrives back on arrakis
after meeting with the conspirators
she confronts paul about giving her a
child but he refuses
chany later comes to paul to ask if he
will give ireland what she wants
as she cannot conceive johnny also
knows that ireland is up to something
against them
and she wants paul out of harm's way
ireland is the wife of paul only in name
their marriage was made only so that
paul could have a claim to the
imperial throne ireland corrino is the
eldest daughter of saddam
she received her education through the
bini jesuit
she was conditioned to be a lady of
refinement and elegance
saddam iv very much expected ireland to
become
empress after his death the binning
jesuit also saw potential in the
princess
and gave her sufficient training so that
they could exploit her at some point in
the future
or she to find herself in a position of
power
still despite expectations ireland
remained only an average benny jesuit
adept
though she still maintained loyalty to
the sisterhood
ireland desires to bear the royal air
herself
and preserve the atreides bloodline for
the bini jesuit
but paul will not touch her though paul
is aware of ireland preventing chani
from conceiving
he allows it he has foreseen in his
prescience
that the birth of his heir will bring
about chaney's death
and he does not want to lose her but
things
change once johnny eventually conceives
having switched to an
ancient frim infertility diet
the empire grows ever more unstable
the spacing guild is refusing to give
over the location of the tupal endante
a sanctuary planet where defeated great
houses can retreat to
ireland suggest that they retaliate by
cutting off the guild's access to spice
but her suggestion is almost unanimously
shot down
stilgar however does not understand why
paul cannot use his prescient power
to locate tuple paul explains to him
that prescience is neither a gift nor
power but a natural consequence
you have certain powers stilgar said
can you not locate the antante despite
the guild
powers paul thought stilgar could just
say
you are prescient can't you trace a path
in the future that leads to tuple
paul looked at the golden surface of the
table
always the same problem how could he
express the limits of the inexpressible
should he speak of fragmentation the
natural destiny of all power
how could someone who never experienced
the spice
change of prescience conceive an
awareness containing no
localized space time no personal
image vector nor associated sensory
captives
he looked at aliyah found her attention
on ireland
aaliyah sensed his movement glanced at
him nodded toward ireland
ah yes any answer they gave
would find its way into one of ireland's
special reports to the bini jesuit
they never gave up seeking an answer to
their quizets hadarac
stilgar though deserved an answer of
some kind
for that matter so did ireland
the uninitiated tried to conceive of
prescience as obeying a natural law
paul said he steepled his hands in front
of him
but it'd be just as correct to say it's
heaven speaking to us
that being able to read the future is a
harmonious act of man's being
in other words prediction is a natural
consequence
in the wave of the present it wears the
guise of nature you see
but such powers cannot be used from an
attitude that pre-states aims and
purposes
does a chip caught in the wave say where
it's going
there is no cause and effect in the
oracle
cars becomes occasions of conveying
convictions and confluences
places where the currents meet accepting
prescience
you feel your being with concepts of
repugnant to intellect
your intellectual consciousness
therefore rejects them
in rejecting intellect becomes a part of
the process
and is subjugated you cannot do it
stillgar asked were i to seek to pile
with prescience
paul said speaking directly to ireland
this might hide too pile chaos
ireland protested it has no no
consistency i did say
it obeys no natural law paul said
ireland is irritated by the lack of
preciseness in paul's vision
stilgar merely cannot comprehend how
paul's godly powers
could be limited in such a way many
people of the imperium are seeking
constitution
they desire limits on paul's imperial
control
paul's priest corba suggests that
constitution
could begin as a religious one but paul
rejects
any idea of a constitution calling it
tyranny
according to ireland many in the
imperium have grown nostalgic
and they look back on the time in which
her father shaddaam ruled
as better days paul is grateful for her
insight
the conspiracy against paul atreides is
a complicated one
the guild navigator edric is able to
shield the conspiracy
from paul's prescience due to a property
oppressions
which causes oracles to interfere with
each other's sight
the spacing guild has come to arrakis
and brought a gift for paul
agola of the dead dunk in idaho who was
paul's childhood teacher
who died 14 years earlier on arrakis in
the novel dune
they have named this goal a hate and
also conditioned him as a mentat
they hope the presence of this gola will
undermine paul's ability to rule
by forcing paul to question not only
himself but the empire he has created
the gola also has another even darker
purpose
paul's acceptance of the gift also
weakens his support amongst the freemen
who see the clay laksu and their tools
as unclean
[Music]
it was stunk in idaho it could not be
duncan idaho yet it was captive memories
absorbed in the womb
during that moment of her mother's spice
change identified this man for leah
by rihanna decipherment which cut
through all camouflage
paul was seeing him she knew out of
countless personal experiences
out of gratitudes and youthful sharing
it was
duncan aaliyah shuddered there could
only be one answer
this was a tlalaksu gola a being
reconstructed from the dead flesh of the
original
that original had perished saving paul
this could only be a product of the
axolotl tanks
the gola walked with the cocked-footed
alertness of a master swordsman
he came to a halt as the ambassador's
tank glided to a stop
ten paces from the steps of the deus in
the beni jesuit ways she could not
escape
aaliyah read paul's disquiet he no
longer looked at the figure out of his
past
not looking his whole being stared
muscles strained against restrictions as
he nodded to the guild ambassador
said i am told your name is edric
we welcome you to our court in the hope
that this will bring new understanding
between
us the steersman assumed a siberidic
reclining pose
in his orange gas popped a melange
capsule into his mouth before meeting
paul's gaze
the tiny transducer orbiting a corner of
the guildsman's tank
reproduced a coughing sound then the
rasping uninvolved voice
i abase myself before my emperor
and beg leave to present my credentials
and offer a small gift
an aide passed a scroll up to stilgar
who studied it
scowling then nodded to paul both
stilgar and paul turned toward the gola
standing patiently below the dais
indeed my emperor has discerned the gift
edrick said we are pleased to accept
your credentials
paul said explain the gift edric rolled
in the tank
bringing his attention to bear on the
gola
this man is called hate he said
spelling the name according to our
investigators
he has a most curious history
he was killed here on arrakis a grievous
head wound
which required many months of regrowth
the body was sowed to the binite lalacs
as that of a master swordsman an
adept of the gianna's school it came to
our
attention that this must be duncan idaho
the trusted retainer of your household
we brought him here as a gift befitting
an
emperor edrick peered up at paul
is it not idaho sire
restraint and caution gripped paul's
voice
he has the aspect of idaho does paul see
something i don't
elia wondered no it's duncan
the man called hate stood impassively
metal
eyes fixed straight ahead body relaxed
no sign escaped him to indicate he knew
himself to be the object of discussion
according to our best knowledge it's
idaho
edric said he's called hate now paul
said
a curious name sire
there is no divining why the talay laksu
bestow
names edrick said but names can be
changed the tlalaksu name is of little
importance this is a telaelaksu thing
paul thought
there's the problem the benning tlalex
held little attachment to phenomenal
nature
good and evil carried strange meanings
in their philosophy
what might they have incorporated into
idaho's flesh
out of design or whim paul glanced at
stilgar
known at the friman's superstitious ah
it was an emotion echoed all through his
friend guard
stilgar's mind would be speculating
about the lowsome habits of guildsman
of tlaxu and of golus
turning toward the gola paul said hate
is that your only name a serene smile
spread over the gola's dark features
the metal eyes lifted centering on paul
but maintained their mechanical stare
that's how i am cold my lord
hate the situation becomes even more
complicated
due to paul's sister aaliyah who is now
maturing into a woman
aaliyah is exceptionally powerful with
all the skills of a beni jesuit reverend
mother
elia is irresistibly attracted to hate
the dunk in idaho gola
aaliyah and haight investigate the
appearance of a female corpse
near the city arakin hate due to his
computational abilities as a mintat
realizes that the fact that no one has
been reported as missing
implies a delay laksu plot they realize
that the dead woman has likely been
replaced by a face dancer
sensing plans within plans paul demands
to see the reverend mother gaius helen
mohammed
she fears that paul will kill her due to
her part in the conspiracy
but instead she discovers that paul
wishes to bargain with her
he offers to produce a child with
ireland through artificial insemination
the reverend mother is disgusted
understanding that such an act would
violate the butlerian jihad
and also she understands that no child
born this way
would be a candidate for the golden lion
throne
still the benny jesuit are desperate to
regain control of the atreides genes
though if they admit it to the existence
of such a child
it would jeopardize their own position
within the empire
the reverend mother decides that she
must consult with the sisterhood
chani has conceived her pregnancy begins
to experience problems
due to the contraceptives in her system
shawnee immediately realizes that
ireland must be the culprit
and would have killed her if not for
paul's intervention
paul has spent more and more time with
the goal of hate
during this time he realized that it may
even be possible
to restore the gola's original memories
little does he know
this is precisely the key to the tlelaxu
plot surrounding the gola hate
in dune paul trained a group of
extremely deadly
and extremely loyal death commandos
known as the fatah king
in dune messiah oatham one of paul's
former commandos
reveals evidence of a frimen conspiracy
against paul
many fremen have grown disillusioned
with the world that muadeeb has made
otham's daughter lichna comes to paul
and insists that her father has a
message for him
he asked for paul to meet with him in
secret
paul notices then that lichna is not
actually lichna
she is a tilaksu face dancer but paul
allows this to happen
he has seen this in his prescience
oatham gives paul his play laksu dwarf
servant named bijas
who has the ability to record faces
names and details like a machine
paul accepts bija's reluctantly though
he is disturbed because he has not seen
the dwarf in any vision
be jazz do recalled you'll call me
the dwarf stepped into the room from the
courtyard
an alert expression of worry on his face
you have a new master bijaz durie said
she stared at paul you may call him
usual
that's the base of the pillar the jaw
said translating
how can usual be base when i am the
basis thing
living he always speaks thus oatham
apologized
i do not speak bijar said i operate a
machine called language
it creaks and groans but is mine own
a toy laksu toy learned and alert paul
thought
the mini tlaylax never threw away
something this valuable
he turned studied the dwarf round
melange eyes
returned his stare shortly after paul
accepts bijaz
and sends him away with stilgar a stone
burner is set off in oatham's home
it destroys the area and blinds many
people
including paul himself but to the
surprise of everyone else
especially the fremen paul does not need
eyes to see according to friend
tradition
the blind are abandoned in the desert
but paul's oracular powers are such
that he can foresee in his mind's eye
everything that happens as if he had
eyes
paul shocks the fremen who take this as
more evidence of his divinity
by following his visions perfectly paul
can see
even the most slight details around him
this only makes him appear more godlike
to those around him
further establishing his divinity in the
minds of many
but this is a curse becoming blind has
forced paul
to never stray from his vision he is
unable to change even the smallest part
of his destiny
while maintaining his appearance as
sighted
as the frimen conspiracy comes to light
it is learned that
korba former fedokin warrior who is now
a high priest of paul's church
is an enemy as well as frim and naives
who are convinced of his innocence await
in the hall
aaliyah receives a letter from the lady
jessica
a few naives had come out to observe the
treatment accorded a fellow friend
they'd brought on the clamor exciting
corba to protest his innocence
aaliyah moved her gaze across the friman
faces
trying to recapture memories of the
original men
the present blotted out the past they'd
all become hedonists
samplers of pleasures most men couldn't
even imagine
their uneasy glances she saw strayed
often to the doorway
into the chamber where they would meet
they were thinking of muadib's blind
sight
a new manifestation of mysterious powers
by their law a blind man should be
abandoned in the desert
his water given up to shy hallud but
eyeless muadeeb saw them
they disliked buildings too and felt
vulnerable in space built above the
ground
give them a proper cave cut from rock
then they could relax
but not here not with this new
mua deeb waiting inside as she turned to
go down to the meeting
she saw the letter where she'd left it
on the table by the door
the latest message from their mother
despite the special reverence held for
kaladan as the place of paul's birth
the lady jessica had emphasized her
refusal to make her planet a stop on the
hash
no doubt my son is an epical figure of
history
she'd written but i cannot see this as
an excuse
for submitting to a rabble invasion
aaliyah touched the letter experienced
an odd sensation of mutual contact
the paper had been in her mother's hands
such an archaic device
the letter but personal in a way that no
recording could achieve
written in the atreides battle tongue it
represented an almost
invulnerable privacy of communication
thinking of her mother afflicted aaliyah
with the usual inward blurring
the spice changed that it mixed the
psyches of mother and daughter
forced her at times to think of paul as
a son to whom she had given birth
the capsule of complex oneness could
present her own father as a lover
ghost shadows cavorted her mind people
of possibility
aaliyah reviewed the letter as she
walked down the ramp to the antechamber
where her guard amazons waited you
produce
a deadly paradox jessica had written
government cannot be religious and
self-assertive
at the same time religious experience
needs a spontaneity
which laws inevitably suppress and you
cannot govern without laws
your laws eventually must replace
morality
replace conscience replace even the
religion by which you think to govern
sacred ritual must spring from praise
and holy yearnings which hammer out a
significant morality
government on the other hand is a
cultural organism particularly attracted
to doubts
questions and contentions i see the day
coming when ceremony must take the place
of faith
and symbolism replaces morality
korba who has now been brought to the
gallery
has denied the allegations against him
claiming that he took no part in the
conspiracy to take down paul atreides
where is muaddim he asked my brother has
delegated me
to reside as a reverent mother aliyah
said
hearing this the naives in the gallery
begin raising their voices in protest
silence aliyah commanded in the abrupt
quiet she said
is it not frim in law that a reverend
mother presides when life and death are
at
issue as the gravity of her statement
penetrated
stillness came over the naives but
aaliyah marked angry stares across the
rows of
faces she named them in her mind for a
discussion in council
horbors rafiri tasmin
sajeed umbu leg
the names carried pieces of dune in them
ambu siege
tasman sink horrible's gap
she turned her attention to corba
observing her attention
korba lifted his chin said i protest
my innocence his tongue flickered
between his teeth as he spoke
not by word or deed have i been traitor
to my friend
vows i demand to confront my accuser
a simple enough protest aaliyah thought
and she saw that it had produced a
considerable effect on the naives
they knew korba he was one of them
to become a naive he proved his friend
courage and caution
not brilliant korba but reliable
not one to lead a jihad perhaps but a
good choice as supply officer
not a crusader but one who cherished the
old frimen virtues
the tribe is paramount otham's bitter
words
as paul had recited them swept through
aaliyah's mind
she scanned the gallery any of those men
might see himself in corpus place
some for good reason but an innocent
naive was as dangerous as a guilty one
here
korba felt it too who accuses me
he demanded i have a friend right to
confront my accuser
perhaps you accuse yourself aaliyah said
before he could mask it mystical tara
lay briefly on corby's face
it was there for anyone to read with her
powers
aaliyah had but to accuse him herself
saying she brought the evidence from the
shadow region
the alam al-mithel our enemies have
friend allies
aliyah pressed water traps have been
destroyed
cannots blasted plantings poison and
storage basins plundered
and now they've stolen a worm from the
desert
taken it to another world the voice of
this intrusion
was known to all of them
came through the doorway from the hull
pressed through the guard ranks and
crossed to alia's side
johnny accompanying him remained on the
sidelines
my lord stilgar said refusing to look at
paul's face paul aimed his empty sockets
at the gallery
then down to corba what koba no words of
praise
muttering could be heard in the gallery
it grew louder
isolated words and phrases audible
law for the blind friend way in the
desert
who breaks who says i am blind
paul demanded he faced the gallery
you rai theory i see you're wearing gold
today and that blue shirt beneath it
which still has
dust on it from the streets you always
were untidy
rajifiri made a warding gesture three
fingers against evil
point those fingers at yourself paul
shouted
we know where the evil is he turned back
to corba
there's guilt on your face corba not my
guilt
i may have associated with the guilty
but no he broke off shot a frightened
look at the gallery
taking her cue from paul aaliyah rose
stepped down to the floor of the chamber
advanced to the edge of corby's table
from a range of less than a meter
she stared down at him silent and
intimidating
corbin cowered under the burden of eyes
he fidgeted
shot anxious glances at the gallery
whose eyes do you seek up there
paul asked you cannot see corber blurted
i don't need eyes to see you paul said
and he begin describing corba every
movement
every twitch every alarmed pleading look
at the gallery
corbeth mustard a pitiful heir of
pomposity to plead
who accuses me otham
accuses you alia said but otham's dead
corber protested how did you know that
paul asked
through your spy system oh yes we know
about your spies and couriers
we know who brought the stone burner
here from tara hell
it was for the defense of the quizurat
corber blurted
is that how it got into your traitorous
hands paul
asked it was stolen and we corbett fell
silent swallowed his gaze darted left
and right
everyone knows i have been the voice of
love for muadeeb
he stared at the gallery how can a dead
man accuse a frimen
otham's voice isn't dead aaliyah said
she stopped as paul touched her arm
otham sent us his voice paul said
it gives the names the acts of treachery
the meeting places and the times do you
miss certain faces in the council of
naibs korba
where are merkur and fash keeg the lame
isn't with us today and takum where is
he
korva shook his head from side to side
they fled arrakis with the stolen
worm paul said even if i freed you now
korba shai halud would have your water
for your part in this
why don't i free you corpora think of
all those men
whose eyes were taken the men who cannot
see as i see
they have families and friends corba
where could you hide from them it was an
accident korba pleaded anyway they're
getting play laksu
again he subsided who knows what
bondage goes with metal eyes paul asked
the naives in their gallery begin
exchanging whispered comments
speaking behind raised hands they gazed
coldly at corban now
corba demands to face his accuser but
paul says his accuser is oatham
they have his voice by way of bajas the
other freyman conspirators have fled
iraqis with the worm they kidnapped
korba insists that he be judged by
friman law
and stilgar agrees because he plans to
take care of corba himself later
aaliyah realizes that this was a plan
between paul and stillgaard to flush out
the other traitors
as hate the dunk in idaho gola
interrogates the dwarf bijaws later
the clay laksu plot pans out hate had
been implanted with a secret command
even he was not aware of it is revealed
that bijaz was secretly a tlelaxum
master
with a hidden purpose by use of an
extremely specific humming intonation
be jaws implants conditioning that will
force duncan to kill
paul and the appropriate instance after
this interrogation
duncan remembers none of this aaliyah
has grown
frustrated she wishes to see as her
brother paul sees
she has consumed an enormous dose of
spice
in an attempt to induce spice strengths
hate finds her in this state she tells
him that the benny jesuit are hoping to
get their breeding program back in line
by getting paul's child or hers though
she cannot see who the father of her
child will be
however hate realizes that she is likely
overdosed on spice
and he could not bear the thought of
ely's death he wants to call for a
doctor
aaliyah realizes in that moment that the
gola loves her
and the doctor is called to help with
her overdose
aaliyah tells hate that she wishes she
were not a part of paul's story
that she wants the ability to laugh and
love
she also asked duncan if he loves her
and he admits that he does
he tries to get her to sleep but she
tells him about the plot against paul
and how bad it has become she drips off
thinking of the child she will have one
day
and how that child will be pre-born just
as she was
as chany's time to give birth nears paul
and chani journeyed to siege taboor
with a group of odd companions bijaz
the tlalaksu dwarf the gola hate
edrick the guild steersman ambassador
gaius helen mohammed
the bini jesuit reverend mother lichna
oatham's strange daughter who paul knew
was secretly the telalak sue face dancer
skytel
stilgar and his favorite wife hera the
princess ireland
adelia chani is confused as to why paul
has brought so many with them into the
desert including
enemies as chonning looks out into the
desert near the siege
where she will give birth hate insists
that she must come inside to avoid the
coming sandstorm
for some reason hate is gripped by the
fear that chany will die
and that paul will tell him so he does
not yet understand that the panic is due
to his clay lack suit conditioning
which was activated earlier by the dwarf
bajas
shawnee dies giving birth once paul
receives the news
the grief of his loss is too much to
bear
paul stumbles and is truly blind now
having removed himself from the prison
of his own precise
vision paul's reaction to johnny's death
finally triggers hate's compulsion and
he attempts to kill paul
by stabbing him with a knife however the
inner turmoil is so great
that duncan idaho's gola body reacts
against its own programming
and recovers duncan's full consciousness
he now remembers his previous life and
is no longer bound to play laksu
programming
paul discovers that chani has given
birth to twins
they are pre-born just as his sister
aaliyah was
born into the world with access to
ancestral memories
thanks to the combinations of their
genes and chinese consumption of spice
while pregnant
paul is shocked that in no vision had he
foreseen twins
lichna who reveals herself to be the
tlalaksu face dancer skytell
offers to revive chani as a gola in
exchange for all of paul's chome company
holdings
this was the clay laksu plot from the
beginning to convince paul
that the memories of agola could be
reawakened and to use
this as leverage upon chani's death
i am skytell eight leilaksu of the face
dancers
and i would know a thing before we
bargain
is that agola i see behind you or duncan
idaho
it's duncan idaho paul said and i will
not bargain with you
i think you'll bargain skytell said
duncan paul said speaking over his
shoulder
will you kill this plalax you if i ask
yes my lord there was the suppressed
rage of a berserker in idaho's voice
wait elia said you don't know what
you're rejecting
but i do know paul said
so it's truly duncan idaho of the
atreides
skytell said we found the lever
agola can regain his past paul heard
footsteps
something brushed past him on the left
skytale's voice came from behind him now
what do you remember of your past duncan
everything from my childhood on
i even remember you at the tank when
they removed me from it
idaho said wonderful skytell breathe
wonderful paul heard the voice moving
i need a vision he thought darkness
frustrated him benny jesuit training
warned him of terrifying menace in
skytell
yet the creature remained a voice a
shadow of movement
entirely beyond him are these the
atreides babies
skytell asked hera paul cried
get her away from there stay where you
are
skytel shouted all of you i warn you
a face dancer can move faster than you
suspect
my night can have both these lies before
you touch me
paul felt someone touch his right arm
then move to the right
that's far enough aaliyah skytell said
aaliyah paul said don't
it's my fault aaliyah groaned my fault
atreides skytell said shall we bargain
now
behind him paul heard a single horse
curse his throat constricted at the
suppressed violence in idaho's voice
idaho must not break skytale would kill
the babies
to strike a bargain one requires a thing
to sell
skytell said not so atreides
will you have your johnny back we can
restore her to you
agola atreides agola with full
memory but we must hurry call your
friends to bring a cryologic tank to
preserve the flesh
to hear chany's voice once more paul
thought
to fill her presence beside me ah
that's why they gave me idaho as a gola
to let me discover how much the
recreation is like the original
but now full restoration at their price
i'd be a delay laksu tool for
forevermore
and chani chained to the same fate by a
threat to our children
exposed once more to the quizzerats
plotting
what pressures would you use to restore
choni's memories to her
paul asked fighting to keep his voice
calm
would you condition her to kill one of
her own children
we use whatever pressures we need
skytell said
what say you atraedes aaliyah
paul said bargain with this thing
i cannot bargain with what i cannot see
a wise choice skytell gloated
well aaliyah what do you offer me as
your brother's agent
paul lowered his head bringing himself
to stillness within stillness
he glimpsed something just then like a
vision but not a vision
it had been a knife close to him there
give me a moment to think elias said my
knife is patient
skytel said but sean his flesh is not
take a reasonable amount of time
paul felt himself blinking it could not
be
but it was he felt eyes their vantage
point was odd
they moved in an erratic way there
the knife swam in his view with the
breath stealing shock
paul recognized the viewpoint
[Music]
it was that of one of his children he
was seeing skytell's knife hand from
within the creche
it glittered only inches from him
yes and he could see himself across the
room as well
head down standing quietly a figure of
no menace
ignored by the others in this room
to begin you might assign us all your
chome holdings
skytell suggested
all of them aliyah protested all
watching himself through the eyes in the
creche paul
slipped his chris knife from his belt
sheath the movement produced a strange
sensation of duality
he measured the distance the angle
there'd be no second
chance he prepared his body then in the
beni jesuit way
armed himself like a cocked spring for a
single concentrated movement
a prana thing requiring all his muscles
balanced in one exquisite unity
the chris knife leaped from his hand the
milky blur of it flashed into skytell's
right eye
jerk the face dancer's head back skytel
threw both hands up and staggered
backwards
against the wall his knife clattered off
the ceiling
to hit the floor skytale rebounded from
the wall
he fell face forward dead before he
touched the floor
the reawakening of duncan's memories
confirms to paul
that it is indeed possible to restore
chani as she once was
still paul refuses understanding
that even if they were to bring chani
back that clay laksu would likely
program the gola
in some diabolical way as they did with
duncan
though paul is blind due to escaping his
oracular trap
he manages to kill skytell with a dagger
by tapping into the vision of his
preborn son
paul names the boy child lato for his
father
and the girl gennima meaning spoil of
war
bijaz comes in and insists that the plan
succeeded
despite skytel's death the tlalaksu knew
that idaho thought of paul as the son he
never had
so he would not kill him if he
resurfaced
he offers again to restore chani and
paul is more tempted than before
he orders duncan to kill bijaz to
prevent this
and duncan does now that paul is truly
blind
both prophetically and literally he
chooses to embrace friend tradition
he walks into the desert alone his
children will now inherit his
empire until the children come of age
aaliyah will rule as regent duncan does
not believe that paul will perish
in the desert but no one can say for
sure
aaliyah is furious after the loss of
paul
she has edric the guild navigator
executed for his part in the conspiracy
the reverend mother gaius is also
executed
despite paul's previous orders to spare
her life
aaliyah is wracked with grief calling
her brother a fool for giving in to this
path
she has had no more vision since the
death of channy
ireland now insists that she loved paul
but never knew it
ireland has promised to renounce the
bini jesuit
and spend her life training paul's
children
aaliyah can sense ireland's sincerity
duncan realizes that now the bini jesuit
have no hold on any of the atreides
heirs
with ireland on their side aaliyah
pleads with duncan to love her
and tells him that she loves him he does
and agrees to follow her wherever she
leads him
dune messiah was not the novel that
people expected after the epic that was
duned
messiah is meant to illustrate that the
life of muadhi
was a tragic one paul is no true savior
any more than he is a deity he did what
he believed he had to do
but still ultimately just traded one
brand of tyranny for another
paul insists in this novel that people
prefer
tyrants to kind rulers he argues that
freedom results in chaos
in dune messiah we observe a society
where this idea has subsumed an empire
of billions
and resulted in unimaginable slaughter
but this
book is not only an argument against
making individuals into gods
it is also critiquing a system by which
people are conditioned to accept such
individuals
taking into account the long view of
history paul can be blamed for some of
the slaughter which fell upon the
universe
but not all of it there is a system in
place which led to his rise
the entirety of the myth-making and
legend seating that the benny jesuit
started before he was even born
without religions without legends
without prophecy the rule of paul
muadeeb would have never come to pass
and 61 billion lives would have been
saved
the message of doom messiah in a
nutshell
is people are not gods gods are not
governance and most importantly think
for yourself
and never give your faculties away to a
charismatic leader
dune messiah sets up children of dune
ending with the birth of paul's pre-born
children
lato the second and genima who will
become the future rulers of the imperium
lato will continue the golden path that
paul abandoned
he will maneuver fate and transcend time
like paul never could
[Music]
you